abu lenval on soutient charlie hebdo
aucun caricaturiste l'état ce festival
de bande dessinée mais ici tout se
partagent le même état d'esprit la
création ne doit pas avoir de limites
la censure chez les toubibs d'alain
servant ne s'affiche que pourra
hors-série réservé aux adultes
à part ça pour lui qui a récemment
dessiné dans une revue en hommage à
charlie hebdo
l'art doit être libre on peut pas dire
que l'art va trop loin
la rive il faut qu'il aille au bout d'os
bull est ce que l'artiste peut amener
corps que ce sont peintes sûrs que ce
soit en caricature
en bande dessinée ou même dans le cinéma
il faut que l'ail que larry aille le
plus loin possible le plus loin possible
mais en respectant la loi
la seule condition que s'impose mathieu
tonneaux son premier ouvrage par des
conséquences d'un voyage dans le temps
son objectif est avant tout que le
lecteur ne se perdent pas dans son
univers de science-fiction ya des
limites de la loi
si jamais ça rentre dans le cadre de la
loi et on n'est pas rendus compte elle
est là pour nous rattraper nous remettre
à notre place il a besoin et je pense ça
fonctionne bien comme ça si on a envie
de changer les choses on change la loi
c'est comme ça que ça marche fort et
pays et c'est aussi simple que ça voilà
moi je pense que je suis dans les
limites de la loi tassement scénario que
tu penses que ça dérange personne ne
parle et doit les entend donc c'est peut
être pas trop de risques mais si un jour
sans m'en rendre compte je dérape et que
l'on me le rappelle eh ben je vais
réfléchir el miraoui en fait c'était pas
très malin voilà je pense avait très
bien fonctionné comme ça ça va être plus
compliqué quoi le moule de cris puis se
doit d'être innocent studio danse
s'intéresse aux petites filles quand il
dessine tout est une question
d'adaptation
il ya des lignes d'un studio danse les
infos c'est le public qui veut ça et ça
s'impose me l'a dit pas on le faisait
jeudi les bd pour l'épicerie avec des
petites chanceuses ça va de soi on pense
arrêter de décider
même des trucs choquant
ou alors on descend plus rien je pense
qu'il faut continuer à dessiner ce qu'on
veut si ça choque maison sachant que des
gens s'il ya des tarifs qui vient de
tuer des gens pour ça dans un temple
contrat avec mais je crois que l'on va
pas s'arrêter dès ce n'est pas ce qu'il
a déclaré river kalachnikov
le message est donc clair pas de limite
pour l'écrire sur les pages blanches la
liberté d'expression semble finalement
avoir de beaux jours devant elle